and the 61,000 145 people have tested  positive an increase of three thousand  nine hundred and ninety-six fifteen  thousand seven hundred and ninety-six  people are currently in hospital with  coronavirus twenty one thousand six  hundred and seventy eight have now sadly  died in hospital an increase of five  hundred eighty six since yesterday this  morning the Office for National  Statistics and the CQC published more  information on the overall impact  including that there have been four  thousand three hundred and forty three  notified deaths  in care homes since Easter the  propulsion of coronavirus deaths in care  homes is around a sixth of the total  which is just below what we see in  normal times I want to make sure that we  bring as much transparency as possible  to important information like this and  so from tomorrow we'll be publishing not  just the number of deaths in hospital  each day but the number of deaths in  care homes and in the community too